[Music]
one of the most powerful integrations
you can make with fire store is algo
Leah it converts your fire store
database into a full-text search engine
which means that you can build instant
search features that are extremely fast
and sophisticated in this episode I'm
going to show you how to automatically
index all of your data in fire store
using cloud functions and then we'll
build an instant search feature on the
front end using angular 6 if you're new
here make sure to LIKE and subscribe and
you can grab the full source code from
angular firebase com if you've been
following the channel for a while you
might remember episode 27 where we
created an algo leah feature with the
real time database but a lot has changed
since then we now have fire store cloud
functions 1.0 angular 6 and algo leah
also released their own angular instant
search component library and I think
this is a really important topic because
I end up using algo leah and a lot of
projects that I work on it provides a
great developer experience and also a
great user experience for surge what
we're building today is just a simple
full-text search feature but it will set
you up to index your data in algo Leah
so you can build more complex features
on top of it every time we save a
document to the fire store database it
will trigger a cloud function that will
then transmit that data over to algo
Leah so it can be indexed on their
servers once it's indexed you can then
query it using one of their client-side
API s in this case we're using angular
but you could also use iOS react or
whatever you want to get started you'll
need to sign up for a now goli account
and they do have a free tier that's
pretty generous and we'll also choose a
data center I'm just going with one in
the u.s. that has the lowest latency
after you sign up head over to the
indices tab and then we'll create our
first index you can think of an index is
just a collection that you want to
search across in our case it'll be a
single firestore collection but you
could even combine multiple sub
collections into a single index to
search across all of your sub
collections throughout your fire store
database now that we have our index
created we need to add some data to it
with a firebase cloud function but first
I want to show you some of the crazy
things that you can do with algo Leah
for example you can tweak the search
ranking formula to control how the
results are returned back to the front
end you can tweak the typos tolerance
for the users search input
you can customize the synonyms if you
have really specific domain logic or
jargon that needs to be used in your
index and that's just barely scratching
the surface you have a ton of control
over how the search engine works and you
don't have to write a single line of
code to make it work the way you want
enough of that for now let's go ahead
and get this thing built head over to
the API keys and grab your application
ID as well as your admin API key make
sure to only use your admin API key and
a secure back end like firebase cloud
functions don't put it in your
client-side angular app now I'm running
firebase in it functions which creates a
function directory in the root of the
project and we'll make sure to select
the typescript option then see the end
of the functions directory and run NPM
install Algol es search this is algo
Lea's node SDK that we can use to update
items in the index but before we can use
it we need to set our API keys in the
cloud functions environment run firebase
functions config set then algo Lea dot
API ID and algo Lea dot API key replace
the quotes with your actual algo Lea
credentials and then run the command now
let's write the cloud function for
adding and removing items from the index
you'll be surprised at how easy this is
let's go ahead and define a variable
called env that holds our functions
environment variables then we'll import
the algo Lea search SDK then we'll
initialize it with our app ID and our
admin API key then we'll set another
variable for our index note that you can
use multiple indices in a single cloud
function the first function we'll set up
will run whenever a new document is
created in firestore and when that
happens we want to upload it to the algo
Lea index so we're listening to the
create event on the zoo collection and
then when that happens we want to
retrieve the data from the newly created
document which we can do by calling snap
data and every index item in algo Lea
also has an object ID we can set this
equal to the firestore document ID just
to keep things consistent then literally
all we have to do is return a promise
from this function that adds the item to
the index which we can do by coin index
add object with our data and object ID
and that's it we're entirely done with
this cloud function but we might also
want to remove items from the index if a
document is deleted we can do that just
as easily by listening to the same
collection but the on delete event and
then we'll grab the object ID and remove
it from the index when that document is
deleted and that's our entire back-end
for our Golia everything happens in the
background and it really shouldn't get
too much more complicated than this
because we can control everything from
the algo Lea dashboard let's go ahead
and deploy this function by running in
firebase deploy only functions and then
we'll test it out on my front end here
in angular I have a button that will add
some random animal data to our zoo
collection and buyer store when that
happens it should trigger that cloud
function and index our data in algo Lea
so you can see here it added a couple
new animals to the collection then if we
switch over to the functions log we
should see that our functions were
deployed successfully and that they're
being invoked when these documents are
created everything is looking good there
let's jump over to the algo Lea
dashboard and see if our data is there
as well when we refresh the page you can
see that our empty index is now
populated with the items from our
firestore database this means that we
can search for text inside of these
documents and it will be robust to typos
and work across multiple properties now
building out the front-end is going to
be just as easy because algo Lea
provides a component library for angular
with just a few components we'll be able
to get search functionality that looks
like this it will automatically populate
the results when the user types into the
form you'll notice here that it not only
searches for the name of the animal but
it will also search for text content
within other properties on that document
and it will also highlight the matching
text in the search result we'll need to
add our API keys to angular but this
time make sure to only use the search
only API key then inside your angular
project go into the environment ts file
and add an object named algo Lea with
your app ID and API key you can also see
we have a firebase object here that's
because we have angularfire 2 installed
you will want to follow the install
instructions on the official repo from
here we can install instant search into
our angular project
the next thing we'll do is import the
NGA is module in our app module and
currently there's one other little thing
we have to do and that's go into the
polyfills TS file and add this little
piece of code to prevent instant search
from throwing an error I also want to
show you how I generate the dummy data
for the index and I'm using a library
called chance J s to make that a little
easier it's not something you'd use in
production but it is pretty fun to mess
around with because L Golia gives us
access to a whole bunch of components to
use for instant search we can just build
out everything directly in the app
component let's go ahead an import
angular firestorm the environment
variables we set earlier and chance J s
then we need to define that
configuration variables for our actual
algo Lea instance it will need the API
keys from our algo Lea environment as
well as the index name then it's going
to show all the results by default so I
want to disable that behavior so I'm
setting up another variable here called
show results then I'm setting up an
event handler function that will listen
to the changes in the input form and if
the actual query has length then we'll
show the results otherwise we'll just
keep it blank and for those who are
curious this is how we generate the
dummy data we'll set up a method here
that creates a new instance of chance
and then chance has a whole bunch of
different helper methods on it that
generate random data so we can just set
up a handful of properties as our animal
data and then we'll go ahead and set
that data in the firestore database
which eventually is going to trigger
that cloud function and then index the
same data in algo lea if we switch over
to the HTML the first thing we'll do is
add a button that will add a new animal
to the database when clicked and then
the most important thing is that we have
this ng a is component that is the
context for the algo lea search instance
it will take our configuration options
as an input argument and then we can set
up a search box that will listen to that
search change to event handler so we
know when to show the results
how Golia returns an array of hits and
we can loop over each hit and provide it
with its own custom template so this is
how you customize the actual search
results which is probably the most
important part
the user experience inside of the actual
hit there's a component called ng AIS
highlight that will highlight the text
if it's included in the users query you
just need to pass it the attribute name
as well as the hit itself as input
properties so that gives us a very basic
search but there's a whole bunch of
other widgets built to the library to do
things like pagination and filtering and
things like that overall I'll go lea
provides a great developer experience
and they don't pay me to say that I'm
just a happy customer I'm gonna go ahead
and wrap things up there if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
if you want to learn more advanced
techniques consider becoming a pro
member at angular firebase comm you'll
get a free copy of my book and a whole
bunch of resources designed to help you
build and ship your app faster thanks
for watching and I'll talk to you soon